alors je mets en scène une partie de ma
vie mais évidemment très fictionnée
aucune préparation évidemment puisque
l'intérêt c'était d'être plus proche de
de mon vrai personnage donc fallait
juste pas que je sois trop caricaturale
l'idée c'était d'aller chercher quelque
chose qui pouvait être qui pouvait
trouver un écho dans le public c'est
c'est d'ailleurs ce que c'est exactement
le même travail que je fais pour la
scène ça me rend hyper heureuse quand je
vois que
une de mes observations est partagée je
me dis bon bah on est plusieurs dans le
cadre donc peut-être que ça mérite
d'être abordé il y a une scène où je
présente une cérémonie quand le cancer
du sein etc évidemment je ferai pas ça
dans la vraie vie parce que j'irai pas
jusqu'au naufrage absolu où j'irai pas
jusqu'à mettre dans l'embarras les gens
pour qu'ils se travaillent mais la
comédie parfois exige qui est un petit
dérapage supplémentaire donc je dirais
que c'est moi un peu plus négligeante
voilà un peu plus un peu moins un peu
moins scolaire elle est un peu elle sort
un tout petit peu des clous alors que
moi je suis quand même assez sage on va
dire